[Musique]
la directrice des ressources humaines de
charlie hebdo a été exfiltré de chez
elle hier en raison de menaces jugées
sérieuses ce sont les officiers de
sécurité qui la protège depuis
maintenant cinq ans qui ont reçu ces
menaces ni ton précise et circonstanciée
on a laissé s'installer s'installer ce
séparatisme qui se propage qui gangrène
notre pays
mais ça moi je pense que monsieur macro
salle arrange parce qu'il espère une
chose
il a plus de parti il a pas de majorité
on voit tous les jours vous avez d'abord
y perdre les élections à chaque élection
la république en marche et tous les
jours vous avez des membres de la
république en marche qui démissionne de
ce parti qui est en partie virtuelle
il avait promis de faire de la politique
autrement mais se déchirent finalement
comme les autres
le numéro deux pierre person a
démissionné hier de ses fonctions à la
république en marche suivie par la
désormais ex porte parole leur verger la
république a marre je n'existe pas sur
le terrain elles existent parce qu'elles
veulent elles macron a été élu présent
la république pour le reste leur public
en marche est une illusion n'y a pas
d'unité intellectuel politique
idéologique de ce parti c'était le parti
de la victoire quand il ya plus de
victoires eh bien il ya plus de six
manches ce journal et ses personnels qui
sont de nouveau la cible d'attaqués
ignoble d'antisémite 10 d'avis qui
défigure la religion de millions de
musulmans pacifiques et ceux pour qui la
france devrait vivre sous la loi d'une
sorte de sharjah et du blasphème contre
haye comme on peut ça a été un petit les
locaux sont sains sont à un blockhaus
l'adresse n'est pas dans le journal
personne ne sait où on se trouve
dray avec j'ai donc demandé à la lecture
des faits que vous évoquez d'abord
qu'une protection puissent être
évidemment bien référé pour l'ensemble
du personnel de charlie hebdo
quand je vois ce matin ce qui se passe
avec la comptable de charlie hebdo
je me dis que la france est en très
grand danger parce que personne n'aurait
imaginé ya encore trente ans qu'il y ait
des journalistes qu'ils puissent se
faire menacer de mort ceux qui ont
commis ces actes horribles qui nous ont
meurtris en 2015 poursuivez un objectif
politique savait lequel instaurer un
clivage en france entre d'un côté les
musulmans et de l'autre côté le reste du
peuple français
nous devons refuser ce clivage notre
peuple c'est créolisé vous ne le savez
pas vous ne voulez pas le savoir vous ne
voulez pas en entendre parler
vous n'avez pas vu comment elle fait le
peuple français aujourd'hui
vous ne savez pas qui sait vous ne vous
balader jamais bien sûr que le peuple
français a commencé une forme de
créolisation qui est nouvelle dans notre
histoire il faut pas en avoir peur
c'est bien on avance on bouge
qu'on ne me dise pas qu'aucun d'entre
eux n'a pas pensé à ça la république tu
vois la république tu vois la république
sera la république française se voir la
république du 4 septembre 1870
c'est en fait la revendication d'une
société multiculturelle et jean luc
mélenchon auxerre est habité par l'idée
d'ethniciser les relations humaines et
10 et la réalité de la france
aujourd'hui il faut pas s'en plaindre
mois samassa vous savez je pense qu'on a
un concept qui est très bien c'est celui
de l'assimilation républicaine et celui
des valeurs républicaines
on n'a pas besoin d'inventer des
concepts alors même que ce concept-là
subi des coups de boutoir régulièrement
chacun peut comprendre que l'on vient à
l'école habillée d'une façon disons je
dirais républicaine c'est à dire qui
permettent une plus grande égalité entre
tous
l'école n'est pas un lieu comme les
autres n'avaient pas à l'école comme
vous allez
à la plage ou comme vous aller en boîte
de nuit est ce que finalement pour
certains et pour blanc caire on a
l'impression que le problème c'est le
nombril des filles
moi je pense que le problème c'est le
regard des hommes le vrai truc qui me
gêne là dedans c'est le fait que la
consigne porte plus sur les chics sur
les garçons à défaut d'avoir une
définition claire du ministre de
l'éducation des professeurs d'histoire
suggère des vêtements datant de la
révolution française comme ses dessins
de sans culottes partager avec ironie
[Musique]